[Music]
30 years ago one of the all-time great
films was released
goodfellas the martin scorsese epic
starring robert de niro joe pesci and
ray liotta
it was a watershed moment for american
gangster movies as well as in scorsese's
career
this week a new book is out detailing
the dramatic making
of goodfellas and why it remains so
relevant today the book is called
made men once again proves that behind
the movie
the truth is even better
as far back as i can remember i always
wanted to be a gangster
why does goodfellas remain so relevant
today
well despite the fact that it's about
incredibly degenerate people goodfellas
remains pertinent because it's a fun
movie to watch it's just a real trip
glenn kenney is the author of made men
the book tells the story of the making
of goodfellas
which sits in the middle of the great
gangster trifecta
the godfather goodfellas and the
sopranos
the shots are incredible the action is
incredible the acting is unbelievable
there are so many
individual scenes that are quotable
come on let's go for a ride are you
being a
wise guy with me not on network tv not
usually
on network tv
goodfellas is about henry hill played by
ray liotta
as he enters the italian mafia at the
peak of its power
i got the most expensive tree they had
before everything
came crashing down this is a guy who
doesn't have much power
he gets by because he doesn't need power
he's not looking for anything more than
being a criminal because he loves it
because you can park anywhere you want
to get the full story the first source
kenny spoke to was journalist turned
author and screenwriter nick paleggi
it was his best-selling book wiseguy
published in 1985
that began it all nick paletchi is i
think one of the great
not just crime writers in america but
just one of the great nonfiction writers
in america
pelegi started as a print reporter in
1956
with the juiciest assignment you could
imagine covering the mob
and jimmy hoffa's teamsters since i was
getting so much
crime story and crime stories were so
big at the time
this is just a few years before the
godfather
i began keeping notes after decades of
shoe leather crime and city hall
reporting
in the early 80s pelagi was contacted by
a former gangster
then in the witness protection program
that
would be henry hill my background in the
subject
was invaluable because it opened him up
it allowed him to take another step
instead of being
instructional to me he was able to be
emotional wake up henry
hill wasn't supposed to be talking to
anyone but the true stories he gave
pelegi became the basis
for wiseguy i felt that i wanted to read
about
the street guy not the boss i want
instead of writing a book about napoleon
i wanted to write a book about somebody
in napoleon's army there was
jimmy and tommy and me and there was
anthony stabile how you doing wiseguy
got the attention of martin scorsese i
know i'd go and went up in the big
screen as
goodfellas olegi also co-wrote the
screenplay
come on don't be like that the violence
on screen in goodfellas and in the book
is horrific
was it as bad in real life worse
the thing about scorsese at his best and
he's usually very close to his best
is that he always puts life on the
screen what happened
that doesn't mean he's a realistic
director he often uses very lurid
effects to get there
but you always feel like a pulsing vivid
sense
of what the character is going through
and that runs throughout
the entire running time of goodfellas
kenny's book also talks about how some
have knocked unconventional editing
decisions in the film
without a full understanding of the end
goal you talk about some continuity
issues
in the movie but you feel the filmmakers
thought it was more important to get a
performance
than to have everything look perfect in
terms of that continuity
thelma schoonmaker who's been martin
score says he's regular editor since
1980
there's an apocryphal quote you can't
actually say it on network television
but she says matching is for and
it's a synonym with wimps you want me to
be your partner
she believes the emotional quality of
the performance
and the delivery of the line take
precedence over whether or not the cigar
is in your mouth or in your hand
what was martin scorsese trying to say
when he made
good fellas scorsese's relationship to
the subject matter of goodfellas is
decidedly different from his
relationship to the subject matter of
some of his major films prior to that
taxi driver the loneliness of travis
bickle
raging bull the self-destructiveness of
jake lamotta the sexual obsession
jealousy those were all aspects of
scorsese's own character that were
explored in those films
in goodfellas there's a little bit more
detachment
goodfellas beyond marking a moment of
transition
and triumph for scorsese was also the
rare case when a great movie
matched the quality of a great book the
list of writers who've done a book
and then gone on to do a screenplay and
had sort of a seamless transition
and been happy with the final product
that's on screen is very limited
yet you know why most writers
are not god bless them journalists
they did not have to sit in an office
correcting their material every day
a writer especially novelists they
live two and three and maybe four years
all alone
solitary they own the novel if the walls
are red they want those walls red
and they wind up at a movie studio where
the owner of the studio doesn't like red
well that could become a very emotional
thing for them
i think my training as a journalist you
you had to be cooperative you had to
help we want to make this damn thing as
good as possible
and you know you might actually have an
idea that's better than mine
guys good trip good life 30 years after
goodfellas was released
nick pileshi is looking back with pride
but more amusement
honestly i wish i could have done it all
over i wish i could do it all over again
because it was fun he's fantastic and
fun to watch
i mean i had to rewatch it when i knew
it was coming up i have never seen the
movie
the show again you have to watch this
weekend okay requirement
it's one of those movies that when it's
on you just stay with it
i know yes i don't doubt it i don't
doubt it this book is really good made
men
real reveals a lot of stuff that i
didn't know before